my name is Dana Rodriguez I'm a solution
you need are very studio and might be
asking why sighs - you're doing in a
Python conference right like restart
your hands of universe to do some other
piece you have colleagues that eyes are
you sir so stuff like that yep I know so
I also asked that question myself but
the good news is that I also I'm a
Python I work for anaconda for four
years before our studio so I'm being
they play their ecosystem for for all
for a while and I salute you
the way I describe it to most people is
that in the same way that a data
scientist is good at better statistics
than software engineer and more better
so when you engineered an assay station
I was using your the same but for sales
support DevOps and just enough data
science in this case for for our studio
our collection of everything and we
mostly work with our Python on our
champions in different enterprises to
install our Enterprise Products
configure them to whatever the needs are
bring back feature feature request to
the product team so we can know what to
build next in the in the next releases
of our products next slide why is that
important
and this is a lot of reasons and I I
kind of find that that was a good way to
explain these what do my mom what I do
she didn't funny enough sorry about that
funny no she the only title does she
actually understood what that I what I
was doing it was proto manager when I
was a problem on during a previous
company and that was the time that I
actually understood at least what I was
supposed to do so why do these important
is because there is no doubt a Python on
our are the following who's for data
science today I think we know that
everybody in any university is learning
either Python or R and if they're not
learning that they should for example my
uncle who has been working in the
telecommunications industry for 30 years
you're now doing a master's in data
science and they're teaching
Python an R so somehow it became the
teacher for them when they had to do
like their 10 projects and stuff like
that but while that is true for a lot of
things is actually not that true for the
enterprise side of things there is still
a lot that we need to do
there there is a lot of reasons why is
that what the main reason is that the
unnamed company he has a lot of years
and years and decades of of time that
they've been already selling these
enterprise products and the only thing
they do they just focus on selling
enterprise and they're really really
good at that and on the other hand we
are really good at like creating these
amazing communities with a lot of people
and democratizing the the knowledge and
and the power of data science but we are
not really like we're at enterprise
offerings and bringing back the money
that we need to found our communities so
the project that also like we don't have
those companies that understand what
deploy and data science mean and even if
Python and are just software language
like programming languages they're just
different enough and our data science as
it is different enough to make it really
hard to deploy this that type of things
in and scaled it
I wanted the questions that I have
myself is what happens if we fail as a
community on the enterprise why what
happened with with us like with the
people that we like Python on our and we
like hanging out with you guys and stuff
like that I don't think we will fail but
it's something that we need to ask
ourselves what will happen in that case
so super quick agenda is an over your
first studio there's a lot of
misconceptions that I personally had
while I was ended by data community for
a while
what is our student doing around Python
we reticulate Orser labs and also and
focus and the support for python inside
there is tid and then a little bit of
Python and are in production and our
enterprise products and how we help our
customers do that in both lunch in
Jupiter notebooks and Jupiter lands in
universities every Pro and polish in
Jupiter not bookstores to connect so I
will get to that
sorry studio is mostly known for the IDE
and yes we do the art studio ID most
people think that they don't diversity
with this professional services and that
couldn't be further from the truth we
don't do any professional services at
all I don't think we have ever done any
professional services in the 10 years of
live dari studio has all the money comes
from Enterprise Products and licensing
also for the ID
the other thing that people think is
that our students the only company that
those are and maintains our and that is
also very very round like we have some
engineers to work closely with the our
team but it's actually the same way that
anaconda does in super Python is a
bigger project on rstudio and that's
really good news a quick timeline of our
studio we just became 10 years 10 years
old I was founded in 2009 by JJ he like
has a history of building and selling
great companies he sold confusion to
Macromedia a long time ago and then
reports to Microsoft in 2011 was the
first release of theirs to ready he and
a small team built that 2012 was the
first release of shiny so does it
probably the most popular library that
Python people know for our 2014 our
first release of enterprise products
ours to do a server Pro and shiny
separate Pro 2016 we did a big
investment into his Park and the tidy
person maybe people know they hardly vs.
yeah and you know some people are
nodding their heads
so we consolidated I in 2016 at the
divers and he has grown up a lot
we start to hire a bunch of people to
work on that 2017 honor enterprise
purpose to connect 18 database there
Susur laughs which is something that I
was super surprised when I say I still
remember what I was working when I saw
there the postman was McKinney and like
I'm like okay what is happening here
tensorflow we because we made a big
investment for tensorflow
and our enterprise product 2019 we had
1,700 Indies in our conference I was one
of those attendees this year I highly
recommend that you go and see a
different side of the community I was
very surprised of the quality of the
speakers and the quality of people that
go there we're doing it again in January
on San Francisco if you're around you're
more than welcome to go of course and
the second big investment we did this
year is a python and jupiter support in
both the open source and the enterprise
products so yeah so our student does
employ a lot of people that do the most
popular are libraries GD p-- load apply
and my favorites are our marlin and
shiny as a Python user
but this is also like a huge community
in the same way that we have known pipe
and asan sake Leonard we have libraries
on top of that and they know
on top of that is very similar to
different names with a lot of ours which
makes it really hard to pronounce for a
Colombian like me and then the only
party that we have Enterprise Products
oh well I'm gonna talk about this
quit weeks I don't want to like sell the
match and just enterprise stuff but we
have first use every Pro I studio
konnekt and we're gonna talk about those
two things here on our sto package
manager is the third one buddy doesn't
have any Python support for now so I'm
not gonna talk that much about that the
important part here is that all these
tools are open-source and accessible to
everyone and and then oh yeah and then
we have tiny purse products that we sell
and we take that investment and we
create this cycle of like development
and selling more products and making our
better and buy some better and sell more
enterprise products and 20 cycle but if
one part is missing if open-source tools
are missing our product was almost all
their value if SHINee didn't exist we
wouldn't sell any in enterprise products
for example but if we don't have people
when our enter products at the same time
we cannot invest back into the community
and sadly there is very few companies
that have a similar model like this one
of the things that were very proud of is
how many of our company are engineers of
54 percent of the company's engineering
I'm not part of that number even in my
title is reduce engineer because I'm not
like coding every day and doing any any
enterprise development or or open-source
development 54 percent order engineering
is open source which is a really really
big number and what really proud of that
and you can show you what else to do
things of the future and our students a
company that really really wants to be
here in a hundred years
the president right now says only 40 and
then he will he will take into for you
and then our people will take it to 100
but once you have that the mentality you
really change the way you work and you
create products and think about the
future and the people you hire and
everything really so that is something
really powerful that we have I and I
like hello sorry student Python so we're
gonna talk about a couple of things
so I'm gonna talk about stuff that we've
done this year but there's a lot of
stuff that is been happening on the on
day on the behind-the-scenes and there's
a lot more stuff that is gonna happen
next year that I'm really excited to and
again like our studios are really unique
approach that I haven't seen in other
companies about how to do open source on
how to do these thing so I'm really
happy and I would like everyone to join
us in our in this journey the first
thing that we did this is older than 10
this year but it was introduced last
year is ridiculous so ridiculous in our
library and allow is free and open
source for everybody to use and it
allows Python and our users to share
code and libraries and data between the
two languages in a different way you
probably have fear about our own I'm
gonna talk about our or a little bit
later but it's a different way this is
you start on our show and they are shell
creates a Python interpreter inside that
and he controls a pattern interpreter
and it creates some very specific
variables and allows you to change in
code and libraries between data and
libraries between those two the two
languages it allows a lot of flexibility
for our users to use some libraries that
they don't have in Python I'm going to
show a couple of examples on what kind
our users do but on the Python side it
allows opportunities to use
presentations libraries like shiny and
our Mardin which are honestly very
powerful and they're years ahead of what
python has to offer right now they're
both based on aren't iTunes C++ API and
this is really nice if you ever use our
piped or something like that you can
always know the best for the licensing
man and they kind of their functionality
offers but particularly I was really
surprised on the way words because
because it based on these supplies all
this tool just translates very natively
between our and Python so a dictionary
commit concept on our list and there are
framing Python independence becomes and
our data frame so everything just works
as you would expect it to work super
quick on this code we have a Python
function that it could do like a crazy
physics based on the PDS over whatever
that means and you pass a dictionary and
a data frame are returns a dictionary
and the function and inside are you can
for example source this Python script or
you could import it if it was an actual
library and you just called the wrong
simulation function and that is doing
articulate we know the magic of like
creating a Python interpreter sourcing
that code calling the function and
translating from our objects to Python
objects in this case it returns up on
our list which is different than a
Python list but they can tickity
important things that it must really
nice to - whatever you would expect us
on our user in this case our chorus
operate the music and this is like how
will you use a a Python library if you
were an hour user in this case our
doesn't have a Google Maps API Python
does right so you can see the code all
those looks the same base of course
idioms in order and different done in
Python but the important part is the
first line during porting google map
seen in Python and you're also like
importing Google Maps in are using
reticulate and the rest of the Kuwaitis
just converting the logic from one
language to the other but this allows
you to only to their users to use some
Python leverage that they don't exist in
in in our but also if you have like read
proprietary library that's what we see
the most in the enterprise it allows you
to like okay my team how many my team
release Python library and when I use it
in our I don't want to convert to Python
it's a lot of code so you can just use
proprietary libraries very easily from
from our I have a small video let's see
how this works here can i click on this
guy
yes okay so i'm like this is let's see i
wanted to pause it nope I kind of passed
okay let's see how's your so this is an
armored on file and it's important
particularly is using the embassy
dataset to create a CSV then is
important this is a Python chunk into
arm are done using pandas to do some
really simple data cleaning and anything
then is using they are the the PI why
the PI what variable in our deploy
reducing ggplot which is something that
a 44 years people like what is the GU
pull for Python now it could be ggplot2
right it could be a same thing are they
one of the nice things about our
madonna's that go have python and are
showing the same
the same file so that is one part of
that one of the part one one key part of
that powers these this armored or not
book then your armor you can render this
to almost whatever is really incredible
than what is what you can render to to
PDFs to present to powerpoints to Word
documents to like almost anything which
is something really really nice another
example I'll show I verified yeah maybe
I don't have that much time
these okay let's let's try to to epicly
and see if we can all the way I cannot
click on this guy now let me see I need
to move this guy now okay it takes is
great where is this oh you'll see my
mouse there we go there we go anyway so
this is a nice shiny this is render like
a lie alive shiny app and all the logic
on the of this shiny app is built in
Python but all the front in his building
shiny and in this case is doing is doing
to two things it's using the Google Maps
API that I said that he tossed an
existing are so he's using the Python
want to build that map and then he Sosa
is also using a model that is training
Python that it was published I don't
remember exactly by who there is
documentation in that other link but
basically making some prediction about
something like other remix actually
those days but this is a Python model
and the person who build is an our user
he does Chinese he build this in like an
hour because SHINee has this really nice
ApS for fronting and you can build stuff
like this extremely easy and they need
to he took him like aranaut
I don't know where I were to use map to
all the Python stuff I was able to be a
really nice dashboard using Python
library and a Python model that was
imposed impossible to load from our
before so yeah it was really nice so you
can build these reticulation yup that's
how we call these these this kind of
connection of both things now let's go
back to this guy perfect the code is the
code is in the github if you want take a
look the second thing I want to say
optimation
is investment that our students been
doing more around like funding other
people not just build a library but so
the first one is worser laughs and I was
personally super surprised when I saw
then-husband mm wasn't last year 2:17
when waste you probably saw this was
posted these before so laughs and our
studio was one of the first two
companies that sponsor they this
Innovation Lab for just science tools
and idea that we want to have like an
independent laughs for the development
of multilingual data science tools
starts to the super super super you say
this well is super committed to to help
these this type of despair type of
people and it's type of tools to to get
out of the two together to get out there
there is been a lot of work into in two
or so laps they mostly are focusing
right now on Apache ro but when you talk
to them they have a plan to do more
things and we have been talking about
our for a long time and most people are
not gonna be good not gonna see their
impact directly but it's a lot of
reasons to be excited even if you just
read their ideas which csb sort with
perky data locally that's just super
exciting by cell because it's going to
speed up all your stuff a lot but
there's stuff like flights to like do to
move data from to like a transport layer
transfer framework to move data from one
place to another from a server to a
client or multiple clients so this is
all super exciting
nice to use one is part of the teams
that are doing this and the other part
is that I find exciting is is the world
of rapid is doing and it's a couple of
talks about rapid and these sort of
boots that I recommend you to go showing
Vinny is doing a lot of investment as
well in versa labs and I'm using now row
as this as this base layer for doing you
know speeding up computation in the GPU
and having this estándar memory diet in
memory layout for for data frames
unloved investment our students we need
is actually being part of known focus
and this just gives got released so
maybe you saw there stood a lock on the
new focus banner there and we're really
really happy to to make this investment
we're just really committed like now
that our students starting to do stuff
in in Python we really committed to help
in the community like
how can we help you Peter Python pandas
and all this or our role I call this all
these libraries and all the people
mostly that work on them to do more
stuffs are we happy to be one of the
corporate sponsors of no focus now cool
so those are some of the stuff that we
do on the pants on there like you know
you're gonna have to get benefits of
that immediately sometimes stuff that we
do around using Python and reproduction
is that I mean what could go wrong
deploying a Python on our model right
like a lot of things honestly but and
like I mention it like these they're
both language I how hard could it be to
deploy a Python file like it sounds
really easy but the things that they are
just defining of their assets are
different of day they're not
transactional the amount of data is one
or two orders of magnitude different
than what people are used to when
deploying applications when you deploy a
shiny app you need an art process which
is something that I T is not used to
deploy all these are processes are a
scale they're not used to are then used
to python you some cases I still hear
every day Python is not fast enough
original fast enough we cannot deploy
Chania blah blah blah
and these are all meats in a lot of ways
but also true in somewhere west and the
work is not done
it's an ongoing process and honestly I'm
we're really excited to really not
accept I mean yeah I'm excited to listen
to what people are facing but also like
open to hearing what what can we do bear
on this space because I think like I
said the beginning is very important
that we get this right or or we won't
really succeed I believe so for to help
with that we have to well three two
products I'm gonna talk about two the
first one is our studio server Pro and
it allows to scale pattern and our
development within a mountain
environment that fosters collaboration
what that really means is that you mean
style our user prone a server you
connect it to your authentication you
connect it to your scheduler if you have
something like kubernetes or as Lorne
and it allows you to launch Jupiter
notebook now to be the Nova contributor
lab and also our studio sessions are
still 18 sessions in that server so
everyone is working in the same in the
same environment the IT team can manage
libraries are versions Python libraries
Python versions it connects with held up
sam'l all the good things that I do want
and it allows data scientist to be in
the same environment and collaborate you
can share projects with one person
another all the coolest stuff that that
people want the second ways are studio
connect and connect is our content hub
for content hub and execution engine for
your data products again what that means
is that you can take the code and apps
and notebooks that you have in your
laptop or in arastoo's every pro and put
it out there so people can look at it so
what we have done in the last year is
allow them eligible users to deploy
Jupiler notebooks to our studio connect
and you can schedule this to those to be
run a certain time you can deploy of
course shiny you can deploy armor down
our Mart down documents as well so it's
like this this place where all your data
assets leave and there and it's tailored
to to do this type of like workflows
right like that like I said they're
sometimes different and is tailored for
those things - to package manager' super
quick it allows you to create a mirror
of cran behind your firewall it doesn't
happen super for Python today sometimes
I'll talk a lot about that but it's
something that people don't think a lot
I guess maybe win the palatal community
because of anaconda we take a lot of
packaged for granted but it's really
important that we have an enterprise of
rain around that as well
I mean I'll stop with packages out there
one of the things that we we we believe
in our students is to use your favorite
tools as you like to use them and for
our people is our studio and for Python
people is usually Jupiter notebooks
right so we were really proud of that
and we don't really give you anything on
top of that and that is intentional we
don't want to have this magic library
that those and collaboration in Jupiter
so you can have like Google Doc Jupiter
stuff like if we were to do that we will
do it in the open source and then we
will reuse that into our enterprise pros
but we give there we just we just use
the tools that the people want to use
and the second part is that we run this
in your favorite places so I love a
plurality kubernetes a lot of people
have a doctor in the past it
and we allow our enterprise users to run
whenever they want it could be a single
server be multiple servers it could be
in a scheme kubernetes could be in a
storm it could be a combination of those
could be multiple like multiple
kubernetes some people do that they have
one for development for staging for
production so we will allow customers to
do that and the all these things that
look like we don't decide for you
because we want to make our products as
customizable as possible so we can
customize them for what every specific
the customer customer needs they have
yeah this is like a small architectural
diagram so the efforts to yourself a
pro-style and the thing that allows you
to like kubernetes stuff is called
launcher and we have a kubernetes plugin
and you have multiple sections in the
into that communities cluster they're
all powered by doctor and they are you
can add a Python logo I forgot to add a
Python logo there but you set the Python
interpreter logo onto a site of fire and
you can just deploy these things I'll
have I made a video on how that works I
mean and again you can have a
combination of multiple a server or
kubernetes or Islam or multiple those is
really it's really flexible let's see
how this video works so this is their
studio server UI super quickly before
the show you can select the Elector that
you want our studio jupiter notebook or
jupiter lab and when you select that in
a second you can see these behind below
these corners not close to kubernetes
this is running kubernetes i canceling
the CPU the memory and the image that I
wanna use when I click that I launched a
new jupiter notebook session when I
click that it will give me just my
regular jupiter new UI I can't clear
that I can click and click on the
notebook and see you know regular
notebook this is like I said there is
nothing really weird happening but
because it's very transparent it's also
really powerful to the users and we also
don't do anything weird around how you
should manage this this is the
kubernetes dashboard and you can see
very transparently what our studio
server Pro is doing there
I think that's the end of the video
let's see goes back you here
I think it's anything you can just go
back to a home page whatever yeah I
think that's all it does maybe like yeah
I think it stops right there
cool and they the old videos how it
works to deploy these notebooks right
like so double search to every pro
launch irst radius and Jupiter notebooks
in a server or kubernetes or whatever
and how you deploy this is still connect
so this is the same as to your server ID
and this Wantley one little button there
that is a Jupiter plugging any connect
service to do connect if you pasted on
ipi key and you're you have the option
to deploy do the published document or a
document with source and if you deploy
with source you're gonna be able to
schedule this and we're on this notebook
whenever you want it so for example if
he's doing any field process and it
connects to a spark or whatever you are
able to first of all share to the people
who have access to that and then a
schedule it to to be executed whenever
you want and you can get an email for
example or send an email to very
specific people every time it runs so
like I said you can connect this to you
can write any call you want you know
it's a Jupiter notebook you could
connect to a database you connect to a
spark you connect to hive and it will
just execute these this notebook when
you tell it to execute you have all the
logs you have integration again with
whatever authentication you need Active
Directory somehow or to whatever you
have access to control well it might
think that it does it that you don't
have to think about the libraries
because both both for the point China
for deploying and for deploying Jupiter
notebooks it takes a look at what
dependencies you have locally and
reproduces the environment so you are
able to change that of course but by
default it will just work for most
people
even you know that you if you have an
icon and you have one environment it
will reproduce a condo for each one of
these projects so issue if each of those
building up independent and like I said
they will just work you have for the
logs and you have all the all the nice
IT features that that people that people
want
okay so just to end really quickly four
more minutes um I just want to yep I
want to see like share that perspective
from a person who was in the Patel
community and now works for a studio but
like a series to using a lot of
investment by that community so I hope
to stay with all you guys but okay cool
I was writing up okay I have more
minutes okay so what I was saying yeah
oh yeah so I have like I've had like
this perspective of like working for two
different ecosystems companies but you
know like I said and we're gonna be you
know friendly shoulder whatever well
things that I that I realized that we
need to learn more from each other like
a little for a long time we like oh you
shouldn't learn Python you should only
know you should learn the one idea what
I like right and that doesn't really get
us anywhere but I also don't wanna just
to be like super friendly and whatever I
think the competition between our own
Python is really good when you start
looking at the two timelines together of
like and if you look at your the Python
timeline you can see Panda a secular non
PI before like all these people working
this traveese ways and all the old
people work on dramatically as well but
when you put them together with are you
get like a really nice perspective on
like how they have work like I'm
building stuff in top of each other and
I steal ideas from from each other and
that's really good like I will I will I
will really like to like for all of us
to like go to our and see what they're
doing better right like shiny and our
modern are like really really good and
we're not even close to those things so
let's just go there and steal their
ideas and they can come to us I'm still
over good ideas and that is great and I
think that is what really gonna makes us
successful successful at the end so
don't be dismissive and actually go out
there a little bit about that go to our
studio come here in San Francisco I
think you're going to learn a lot I I
did at least for for to see a different
perspective on on all these things
what else do I want to say here yeah
just yeah I just like I said just steal
ideas from each other about you know
like be friends with other people as
well and you know they're people as well
you know
they're nice anyway I'm doing here like
some call to actions follow me on
Twitter I need more more followers to
create my personal brand or whatever
everybody's doing it I need to do it as
well try reticulating shiny of you
haven't I think you will you know I was
surprised I was a hater I'll be honest I
when they told me about it I'm like yeah
there's no way this is nice but it's
pretty nice actually
so try it I think you will be surprised
until you'll be able to build really
nice diverse and we like I didn't know
how to build a freaking - born in
bootstrap now I can do it with
particular than 50 lines or 30 lines so
far and you know our you know I I'm not
my favorite language like Python but you
know I spend the end of the world it
will work and you will get a lot of it
because China has years and years of
like being proven of like bean dip a
really really nice API all day all day
reactive stuff that they have is really
really well done and even though we have
like - and other libraries now in Python
they're really not there yet once you
start looking under the hood we also
have 40 day trial for our product for
products they are like free to use you
just have to put an email but you can
put a fake email if you want that's okay
you don't tell the marketing people that
I said that they're completely free no
strings attached 45 days and you can you
just write them and release it to me
style the downer PMG is tell it where a
Debian file you're on to one
configuration file you install it you
can send me a tweet on and I'll help you
sell it that's fine I'll do something
like that I'll whatever for you guys to
try that and that's it you have any
questions I'll be happy to take them
yeah thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
right right so you can so when when you
I don't have let's see so yeah that is
that you you bet you barely can you
basically can today open one rd session
and one Jupiter session and I think
should use it later on the same file
system right because it's a mount so
when you go to kubernetes or stuff like
that is the same file that we mount it's
the same Mount Sinai network attached
it's an NFS server whatever so you the
same file system and you can just create
an hour file already and you will show
up in your notebook when you refresh or
whatever so it's completely integrated
you just have to create one section of
each of those yeah no we don't have
plans for that we do have plans for like
improving support of Python in the IDE
you can today write Python files in the
IDE and you can start marathon to write
Python code I don't know exactly what's
gonna happen but we do have plans of
improving that it might be using like
the Jupiter protocol to create actual
Jupiter not booking the IDE and maybe
having a different UI that might be the
one thing that happens but yeah right
now is just two independent ideas right
yeah so thank you
you know you have that apply whatever
right do your thing right
so dude deadly can and suddenly I
couldn't positive in the video because I
want to show you how I work but II when
you when when you start right to click
station it creates a PI Y variable and
you can do PI Y this is to call Python
functions but all the names you can just
get them back and the variable can get
the button are I mean Python you can do
the same thing on our variables you can
do our dot whatever so you can
definitely share all the stuff from
those two things yeah that's right B is
a really nice so give it a try yeah
anyway right so there is this two big
difference between those two the first
one is the license particularly
supportive license so you can you know
it's about you 2.0 license you can use
whatever if I remember correctly our PI
2 is a GPL maybe something like that
right so if you were you're able to use
it but in theory we use it for something
professor you have to open source I
don't know your honor about licenses but
licensing in our pack 2 is not the best
so that's one big difference and the
second one is that I don't know exactly
Hart back towards the first time I use
it I kind of hate in my life and the
first time I use a particular I'm like
okay this is actually better I was
expecting the same thing as R by 2 and
this actually really nice and I think
the big difference I'm not an expert on
any of this is that particular is based
on the core R and C and Python C++ API
and that gives them an advantage on how
everything works behind the scenes and
the other difference is that to use
particulate you need to create an art
session and that our session is pins up
a Python interpreter
for our PI to is I think is the opposite
that you have a Python session and I
will connect to an are running our
session so those are like kind of some
differences that they exist
they're separate processes so you can
see them what like in the process
manager yeah this house excels what
right that's another probably okay
that's right so that's one difference
yeah cool
final question no yeah so let's stop the
recording so we're definitely more
interested on what you guys are doing so
come talk to me and see what what you
need I'll be super happy to listen and
bring by the feature to the product team
we are one thing that people want and I
bet most you will tell me is like I hate
alright hey shiny and when I deploy my
flask up this is not the first time we
hear that so we will definitely do
something around that in our sphere
connect does that the first thing that
we will be doing probably early next
year
so more Python stuff is there free on
the underwater for us okay yeah cool
final question awesome thank you thank
you everybody
[Applause]